I'm the editor of the Harvard Business
Review and also it's managing managing
director which means i'm in charge of
both the editorial and the commercial
sides of the magazine the fundamental
job my fundamental job as the editor is
to work with the staff of the other of
the senior editors work with me and for
me to produce that magazine every month
you know nine articles plus other stuff
in the magazine and deliver that to a
quarter of a million important decision
makers in business so the fundamental
job is to put the magazine together the
job of which that I mean that's the work
the role the job is then to be engaged
in a conversation with the staff with
business leaders with academics not only
in business school but in other places
with experts about what the issues are
that are most important to the men and
women who are running important
organizations you know we define our
mission as improving the practice of
Management and its impact in a changing
world and I've sort of sub defined that
and say we're accomplishing our mission
if we help people to become better
leaders if we help people see the future
first if we help people identify and
solve their toughest problems and if we
help people know what really works as
opposed to what's bad and
you